welcome back to our red pill production
vlogs currently sitting in the
headquarters that is known as dan also
this basement where we make things
happen sometimes most of the time dan is
currently playing league of legends oh
hey and I'm currently on the interwebs
oh hey look at that could this possibly
be a moment to uh you know plug the
Alberta film makers podcast Oh seriously
it's a really good podcast especially if
you're into film stuff related in
Alberta look it up it's cool regardless
what we're actually doing here tonight
is we're finalizing the script for the
film we have a very good layout for it
and then we just have to kind of finesse
it um another part of it was we actually
had to make two versions of the script
one of which is Telus friendly so
basically a part of going up to m10 was
obviously informing us of what we want
and all those things that we did but the
other part of it is telling us the rules
of what it we have to deliver and for
tell us it means that our film has to be
rated PG to be a part of their VOD
system and our script is not PG I
wouldn't even consider it pg-13 yeah so
we have to make two versions of it one
that will do the voice-over that is
associated with what we're gonna give
tell us and then what we'll do after
that is actually make a version where
the language is what we want it to be to
really give the effect of what it is
that these what these guys on the
internet are
are actually saying and what their
beliefs are and using the words that
they would use because that's kind of
the point of the whole film is to be
authentic that way so what is this Dan
so this is shark shark well yes this
this is shirk shirk and this is the this
is After Effects this is the animatic
that we were will explain to them what
an animatic is okay so an animatic is
when you take is it's it's an animated
storyboard basically or it's a it's it's
kind of a placeholder animation that
exists to help with timing so you'll
maybe like you like you'll put scratch
track over it or you'll animate it like
you'll actually add like motion to it in
order to in order to get timing and
whatnot down before you ever go go on to
set you know it's it's super common in
animation like it's an entire stage of
animation but it's also used a lot in
action movies yeah we're using it
because we need to time out the process
yes okay well we'll play the first ten
seconds let's see what that looks like
whoa not gonna give away everything Oh
like it's slate to begin with no whoa
whoa you know for a camera major like
for like vlogging and stuff like that
it's awfully using screws I obviously
need to do more vlogging we are done the
first draft of the script it's done
completed first draft yes and basically
we're going to use that for our
auditions that are gonna happen in a
couple days which Dan has already gone
through and picked out his top six
candidates so to speak that'll be pretty
interesting maybe we'll film some of
that as well and show you guys maybe I
don't know I don't think we have
permission from that we would need to
get permission from
individually or I'll just aim this at
Dan's face while they're doing things
when we get reactions from that we we
hired a production manager and he's been
doing a great job at finding finding us
a location thanks Steve thanks Steve
basically it requires a lot of what's
it's time-consuming but it's also about
knowing certain people and knowing how
to obtain certain things in which I had
no experience and really didn't have the
time to deal with while dealing with
other real-life things ya know and Steve
Steve's got some experience and we've
known for years and worked with him tons
so we're super happy to have him on
board so the animatic is done this
script is in its final or forms and we
timed it out now - yeah I guess that's
sort of what that's part of the draft
thing is that before it was a lot of
loose conceptual stuff but it's it's now
kind of a lot more timed out and we've
we've really hammered down some of the
more conceptual aspects of it we got the
location stuff actually finally a really
forward we've got casting calls this
week we talked with set building people
and they're getting us a quote soon I'm
gonna be hounding them tomorrow Jimmy
honey that tomorrow and aside from that
no I mean this is kind of the week where
everything comes together and I would
kinda kind of hopefully fingers crossed
I wouldn't mind if everything can hold
together if we could do like a full full
crew meeting yes Saturday that would be
ideal
and just yeah just a even if it's just a
half-hour hour long kind of
meet-and-greet with everybody and kind
of and introduce you to everyone or
everyone who's willing to to be on to be
introduced yeah um yeah but it's pretty
awesome because it's it's one of those
things where basically everyone who we
initially asked to be on a crew who said
yes which is kind of unheard of
hopefully well I mean we have not
decided the shoot date yet so that
doesn't
it might prove that but we would love to
have a location to actually have that by
our crew meeting yeah so do you
we pretty much have to do yeah pretty
much Steve may pull some rabbits out of
a hat tomorrow which would be amazing
so yeah it's 11:30 at night but I'm
gonna learn how to play Dungeons &
Dragons now okay yeah okay bye
I'm lending her sewing my D&D stuff all
right all right
high five hi